for us art has to be really special and
allows people to really be creative on
their own level we're giving people a
service to show you know things that are
very meaningful to themselves my name is
Asha kamila my name is Janelle Mohan and
we are born of sound we originally met
actually in kindergarten but we've known
each other really from high school
so I figured the musician as well as an
engineer and we were looking at that
kind of static waveform that you see
when you're doing audio recording and
really started asking the question what
does sound look like what does it look
like if I could really see it and that
kind of started us on this journey it's
not static it's constantly moving it's
at once chaotic and we looked at nature
and we said what in nature is doing it
one of the main areas we looked at were
fluid dynamics and how does water move
and we saw this take sound let's take
that energy that sound creates let's put
it through that process and see what it
looks like we started the process about
two and half to three years ago now out
of curiosity and it wasn't until we were
actually pregnant that we decide we
wanted to see our daughter's heartbeat
and when we created that sound form we
showed our friends and they're like oh
my goodness I want my daughter's
heartbeat I want you know to see my
wedding song I want to see my dog's bark
and it was then that we kind of really
realized that once people like see it
and they wrap their minds around the
fact that I can see myself it blows them
away because the options are really
unless you can really create this
meaningful personal artwork from any
sound that can be recorded we realized
to make it into a really polished piece
something that was very artistic we
really needed help from someone whose
business that you know that's what they
do the Intel processors have actually
completely for us open the doors for our
business we have the flexibility of the
Intel two-in-one PC to be mobile between
our home as well as our studio and even
sitting outside having a cup of coffee
still able to answer emails or work on
some social media aspect
their processors allow us to take these
enormous files of audio that we get from
all around the worlds in different
languages in different formats and
create beautiful sound forms by allowing
us to provide these deeply personal and
meaningful custom artworks
we had a soldier who was overseas who
contacted us about creating a special
song form gift for his wife for
Christmas he wanted to create something
for her where she could feel him with
her and something that she could look at
on the wall and know that he loved her
and cared for her and you know is
thinking of her constantly one thing
we'd love to do going forward is do a
further exploration into the actual
sound waves themselves
so maybe 3d print an actual sound wave
we're actually working out another thing
that we're looking at doing is working
with other organizations specifically
for those who are hearing-impaired
there's something about our artwork
where you can see something that you
can't hear and so it's just a way to
bring a sense to someone that may be
missing so that they can experience and
still have that deep connection to that
artwork but also to that person who's
you know giving that message to them
giving them that moment Intel really
powers our processes what we feel are
absolutely spectacular pieces of our
work that you can be proud of the past
lanta generations
you